understanding risk is the most important
thing we fear things that are very
unlikely to result in us getting hurt or
killed and we're way too nonchalant
about things that are life and death
threats to us if we really understood
the risk of not getting physical
activity we probably would be willing to
make big changes in our lives but that's
not so clear on the other hand we may
fear things irrationally or out of
proportion to their level of risk we're
recently able to measure for example
minut amounts of radioactive fallout
from the nuclear disaster in Japan we
wish those things weren't in our
environment but they're being measured
in the trillions of a curie and they are
nowhere near the level of a significant
public health concern that will get more
attention over the coming weeks in all
likelihood than things like air quality
problems from fossil fuels which are
killing many people in this country or
the lack of physical activity which we
can do something about by helping people
and fostering activity by making our
communities easier to walk easier to
bicycle encouraging people to take the
stairs lots of things that we can do on
a community level and on an individual
level to live longer and healthier lives
based on a better understanding of risk